hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from round 10 of
the feeder candidates tournament 2022
now it's uh it's a very short game it's
not a game that you would expect to see
in a candidate's tournament it's uh
incredibly sharp and uh well it's just
not what anyone would would have
expected uh it features the night of uh
sicilian which is of course a very very
uh enjoyable opening to play and watch
but it's very very hard to pull it off
on the absolute top level for example if
you remember uh gary casparo when he you
know he comes uh
out of retirement uh once a year to play
uh to play a
blitz tournament or a rapid tournament
and then with the black pieces in his
last appearance he played the night of
him he lost all i believe all of the
games with the uh with the knight or
defense because it's so difficult to
play it nowadays now it probably can be
played but you have to play the absolute
main line and you have to play it to
perfection because if you don't then it
is just too easy to play it with white
and it's not easy but for
uh you know when you're one of the
strongest players in the world and your
opponent gives you a little bit of
something then you're going to take that
so it's very interesting how the game
develops let's check it out and uh see
why why it happened uh so uh hikaru
opens with pawn to e4 we have c5 alireza
goes for the sicilian defense knight to
f3 d6 and uh d4 uh just going for the
open sicilian captures capture snipes to
f6 knight to c3 and a6 so the knight of
sicilian is on the board uh we have
bishop to e3 going for the english
attack and pawn to e5 violet is a knight
to f3 knights to c6 and bishop to c for
hikaru just playing nice developing
moves with bishop to e6 and now knight
to d5 of course not going for the trade
uh the position has been reached before
uh for example karjakin had it against
yani pognishi in that game bishop
captures on d5 was played it ended in a
draw but they go for the or rather
alireza plays rook to c8 and they now go
into the game that maksim bashir lagrava
played against alexander morozei which
in the 2009 tournament of beel uh where
uh after this uh rook move knight
captures on f6 was played this comes
with check and queen captures on f6 is
the move that motorcycle which played
against the maxima shiela grav but here
alireza plays g captures on f6 and it's
a it's an incredibly ambitious attempt
uh in in an incredibly sharp opening uh
where there's just a lot of potential to
the position white always has to be
careful
when d5 is coming when f5 is coming now
the rook has a semi open g file to use
the bishop can come to g7 maybe to h6 in
the future so there is um
there's a lot that can happen and of
course it is now as of move tended we
have a completely new game so hikaru
just goes back bishop to b3 uh he says i
don't want to capture here even though
uh you're going to have to capture with
the f pawn this will give you this
incredible center and i i don't really
have anything to to play against this so
after this bishop to b3 alireza plays
knight to the e7 and now hikaru castles
king side he's not afraid of this rook
to g8 move uh but uh it is a place
bishop captures on b three eight
captures and now just a d5 so he removed
one of the defenders of the d5 square
and now he executes d5 and as we always
say if you can pull off d5 in the
sicilian you're going to be okay e
captures on d5 by hikaru queen captures
offering a queen trade but hikaru is not
convinced he plays queen e2 now the rook
is coming to the d file and the queen
will have to look for some other uh some
other file to move so knights to f5
putting brethren the bishop here and
rook after d1 we have queen to c6 and
now pawn to c4 not allowing the queen to
capture the pawn of course and now
alireza has to figure out how to play
this it's a very weird position you have
a double def point your king is still in
the center of the board
but you do have a semi-open g file so
maybe something like rook to g8 you
start pushing your h pawn is is maybe
the way to play this but alisa plays
bishop to g7 and he says i'm just going
to castle king side nothing nothing you
know serious is happening here and okay
hikaru takes this time he plays rook to
d5 now he's going to double up on the d
file castles by alireza and rook ate the
d1 we have rook f the e8 and now comes
pawn to h3 and uh alireza goes for pawn
to b5 uh and now hikaru plays c5 which
is a
a very nice idea uh you of course want
to play b4 and have a beautiful passport
on c5 although it's not all that
impressive if alireza plays a5 which is
not what uh what all it is a player but
even without the c5
hikaru had this bishop to c5 which the
engine is just screaming that white
should play uh yeah as there is no move
here uh for black you you just
move the bishop now the queen has access
to d4 square and once the queen reaches
d4 square then it's just uh well black
will not be able to to find a single
move it's it's a really crazy position
even after a captures capture still the
queen is coming to e4 you're gonna you
can play pawn to b3 even pawn to b4 so
it's uh it it's uh it's so it's a
winning position for white but you know
maybe you can uh play it a bit longer
but okay c5 by hikaru he wants to play
b4 and alireza actually allows it he
doesn't play a5 he plays bishop to f8
now attacks the pawn and he cover plays
b4 and i mean why wouldn't he it's a
free b4 move so here uh why did alireza
do all of this well he plays knight to
d4 this was his plan
if he car wastes uh time to play this b4
move then uh now just knight to d4 of
course this is this is gonna win
material the queen is attacked the rook
is attacked and uh is there anything
hikaru can do here that's the question
also this is yes this is the position
from the thumbnail so it's a completely
winning position for higaro hikaru but
you have to play the precise move feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for hikaru already and move 22
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that it's
the only move you have basically
otherwise you're just gonna lose
material for nothing and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is knight captures on d4 so we offer the
rook here and the that's basically it
and you don't really have an option if
you play e captures on d4 which seems
like a pretty good in between move uh
because all of the action on the e file
just queens you for check and you don't
really care uh queens you for checking
is going to move you're going to play
rook characters here and it's just an
overwhelming position black will not be
able to hold this so queen captures on
d5 basically the only thing left for
alireza and now knights the f5 this is
how hikaru's knight gets to this
beautiful square with tempo the queen on
d5 is currently attacked so queen to e4
trying to stop hikaru's attack but now
queen to h5 just putting so much
pressure on black's position and now
bishop to h6 is coming we want to remove
the dark square bishop and
then all of the dark square weaknesses
will be even even weaker uh and he
always will not be able to defend this
we have rook eat the d8 trying to trade
off a pair of rocks but of course hikaru
keeps them on the board just plays rook
to a1 and the rooks are absolutely
useless uh this rook can't really do
anything for this game also this rook
useless
uh so here rook to c6 to defend the a6
pawn but now bishop to h6 by hikaru it's
just a move by move there is nothing
eliza can do of course if you trade
bishops then knight captures with check
then we attack the f7 pawn uh even if
king g7 to prevent queen captures on f7
because you lose then i just rook a3
then rook the g3 is coming there's no
defending this uh so king the h8 was
played by alireza but now still rook a3
and what can you do here queen captures
on b4 if you don't capture this and you
know try and break through here there is
pretty much there's nothing you can play
so this is the only way to go queen
captures on b4 and now just bishop
captures nf8 rook captures an f8 and now
queen to h6 threatening checkmate and
that's it there is no way to stop this
all it is i did play rook to g8 but
luckily for hikaru a very simple rogue
g3 and uh again
the threat remains the same rook capture
sanjit will be followed with queen to g7
checkmate so it is a traded this rook
captures on g3f captures and also it was
in this position on move 32 that alireza
furuja resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so a very
very short video for a very very short
game uh in the first uh as the first
game that we are covering of the
candidates tournament uh but that's just
what happens when you play the night or
if you either get a spectacular victory
or you just uh get destroyed in a
miniature uh like what happened here
against hikaru so uh there's no defense
against queen to g7 checkmate you can
give one check but it's not much after
king to h2 there's no move just queen g7
will be checkmate and that's it so
really really strange game if i showed
this to you like you know uh look at
this game and try and guess where it's
from you would probably say i don't know
you played it uh somewhere you know
blindfold on on leeches or oranges.com
you know you played some bullet and
that's it but no it's actually a
classical game from the candidates
tournament so really really impressive
stuff uh by uh by hikaru just taking uh
advantage of the basically the only
opportunity alireza gave him but in the
nider you know the
you can make no mistakes if you want to
survive
you know if you want to just survive if
you want to keep playing for more if you
want to attack then
of course today in 2022 you have to be
you know engine precise
uh so really impressive stuff we're
going to discuss the standings after we
show at least one more game from round
10 and then we're going to see what this
means for the tournament standings uh
for those of you who
don't know yanipon she has finished his
game from round 10 his game ended in a
draw he played against rajabov and it
was a fairly quick uneventful draw so
we're not going to be covering that one
uh but he did not extend his lead by by
a full point if you guys were wondering
about that so uh we're gonna discuss the
standings after we show one more game uh
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it very nicely done by hikaru perfect
play it was uh very very uh amazing to
watch uh i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to ori and i would like
to thank a friend from the bar in the
library disgusting engine line kenneth
frazier and the clever piggy for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament until it finishes
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day